what part of LA are you from Korea
District South Central yeah
um for you because I know you've been
back and forth between Atlanta and LA
do you feel like the difference in like
because I go to Atlanta and it feels
like a whole different [ __ ] it just
feels like especially during the
pandemic right they never closed so the
[ __ ] is like it's lit all day yeah how
do you like the like you know the
contrast of being in Atlanta a lot now
compared to being out no like obviously
being home
I'm away from distractions yeah people
can't tell me to just pull up I don't
really know nobody in Atlanta like that
only only [ __ ] with Boosie so when I'm
not [ __ ] with him I'm in my own world
just rapping rapping my ass off I can't
go see nobody I can't go just pull up or
you can't pull up on me and be
distracting me like I'm here just I'm
working you know so it's more like a
work thing that's my job [ __ ] it is your
job yeah how long have you actually been
like taking the rap [ __ ] serious how
many years has it been since I really
came out the wound I can't count the
years because I really
just been doing this [ __ ] right for as
long as I can remember do you remember
like uh when you first realized you
could make some money off the rap rap
game because a lot of people they do it
but then they don't really when I turn
like 15 16 yeah start realizing more
but not really knowing everything but
I knew I could do something like this
[ __ ] real right like it could happen for
you so I just kept doing it right
growing up in that area
um
obviously you know nipsy being a legend
coming up from your same section
um was that like a
did you did you grab a lot of
inspiration from someone like nip from
those guys yeah [ __ ] mainly knit yeah
that's where all the inspiration really
came from
growing up and watching him watching
Boosie
but I was able to watch nips up close
because I was around like I went around
him all the time but I was around to see
it around the Watchers grind watch what
he did try to follow the steps the best
way I could but in my own way so
he was a big part of my inspiration for
sure yeah yeah and also it's I always
tell people this that they will never
understand it but like living here
I feel like somehow
Nipsey dying was a bigger loss to La
than Kobe and that's a crazy thing to
say for people who don't live here right
but like
being like being here for both of those
you know you know just Monumental losses
to the city
I just felt like the nipsy death hit
harder man
[ __ ] hit harder than any death really
yeah any like that he he hit us hard
I mean even just like uh him passing
like I know it was temporary but like
the fact like Big E was able to have
everybody pull up over there that
usually be around each other legendary
[ __ ] yeah that's a pretty uh it's pretty
crazy uh you know to think back like
his memory and the respect that he had
amongst people even on that side like
you know was strong enough to have
everyone and their mom in the same spot
at the same time yeah that was dope yeah
not not too many people could pull [ __ ]
off like that 100 100 percent